davidpakman.com
discord is where we are let's go to alec
from the united kingdom alec you're on
the air
yes that's it i literally just joined
they realized i'll be the first
that would be first up i'm sorry about
that um hello yes i'm from the uk um
i guess my question would be mainly
about
coming in because obviously financing
buttons
just got in with kamala um looking
forward to
2022 with the i think i'm not sure which
seats go up i think it'd be congress and
senate right
so for 2020 is there some third voice in
the background right now when between
you and i
it might be i am though so every two
years
all 435 house seats are up for
re-election
and one-third of senate seats so that's
what's up in 2022
okay so i guess the question would be do
you think
do you think that republicans would have
like a high chance of
reclaiming lots of their seats
especially after trump's after party
i did i did a video about this actually
typically
when the when the white house switches
party the next midterm is bad for the
winning party
but i think that circumstances are very
different this time
the senate seats up for re-election
aren't particularly bad for democrats
and it's a real question my hope is that
a lot of these
q anon conspiracy theorists like lauren
beaubert and marjorie taylor green
my hope is that they will be one-term
flukes and that they will lose in 2022.
so i think it's quite plausible that
democrats do okay in the midterms
okay um are there any um moderate
republican season perhaps do you think
um democrats have any chances of
flipping those
yeah i don't have the senate list in
front of me and there's many in the
house
but we'll we'll look at that in more
detail as we get closer to the midterms
no worries man anyway have a good show
say bye i'm curious what are you what
are you doing are you cooking or what
are you working on right now
i'm doing that i mean i just um right
now i'm just reading
you're reading okay all right good and
you're not in a you're not in a factory
or anything
uh it could be just how bad my
microphone is
i'm using a i'm using um head like
basically something here got it laptop
mic so that's probably why
all right alex thank you so much i
appreciate the call
no worries thank you thank you david
pleasure absolute uh absolute and
complete
complete pleasure